ABC common marker
nice
[Music]
I'm George moats and it's my job to make
sure you are as obsessed about
hamburgers as much as I am we 've gone
deep into hamburger history we've
discussed technique we've discussed
method but today is special because
we're headed to the one place we haven't
gone
the cosmos
and there's only one person I could
think of
help take us there
hey look hey astrophysicist Neil
deGrasse Tyson hello pleasure to meet
you thank you for being here by the way
you said you've never been in the cosmos
but Earth is a planet in the cosmos
it's true in this episode we're going to
try to explore the intersection between
burgers and space okay you ready for
this to whatever extent I can assist
that and I will give me some of your uh
your what some rules with you and
burgers if you want me to taste the
burger reduce how much stuff you put on
it I like that you hear that did you
hear that just why have 10 things it
must mean you don't actually like the
burger I couldn't agree because you
gotta what are you doing I agree it's
not a Burger salad it's just a burger in
that sense I'm a purist good I'm a
purist as well okay we have two missions
today let's do it first mission is to
make a burger for space I went to the
NASA food laboratory in Houston in
Houston yeah Planet Houston yes I love
being there the problem was the burger
was not very good well see a lot of what
they do is to create sustenance for you
so you don't cry right
that's a different goal right from
having a really tasty hamburger what I
understand yes astronauts crave
cheeseburger they crave food with an
intensity of flavor because as we've
come to learn under those conditions you
have taste buds become less acute and so
foods that have extra things going on in
them right become that much more valued
what I've done is I think I've developed
a burger that NASA could use if they're
listening hope you're listening because
I've got a great burger for the Mars
mission especially oh okay are you
familiar with the Oklahoma fried onion
burger I've spent a lot of time making
this part no of it yeah okay five basic
ingredients it's super simple it's just
beef cheese bun
salt and onions that's it okay yeah
super simple this is just onion powder
right this is salt and then I thought
the cheese ready for this one I thought
of this in the shower one morning and I
jumped out of the shower to make sure
that I had it right and sure enough I
did
cheese powder
yes is that the chicken powder that goes
in mac and cheese it's a mac and cheese
yeah okay I know so you know in the day
that got me through exams and things in
the middle of the night there it is
right that is that that is mixed up
movie Magic okay we've made a big
meatball here
from what I understand there are some
serious challenges making food for space
you don't want powder anywhere right
zero g the powder yes everywhere you
breathe it in it doesn't settle out yeah
so powder is not good so things that
have surface tension like very helpful
right like mustards and sauces yes so
that it does not scatter right across
nice
can't do that in zero g can you can't
flip a burger yeah if you did no you
could flip it it just won't return to
the right
I just want to make sure you smell this
it looks good we're actually not gonna
eat this
why are you cooking food in front of me
there it is oh that's my choice I eat
this or this it's the same thing
it's the same thing
well it's dehydrated it's obviously it's
it's freeze-dried yeah there's no this
is there's no liquid in here no liquid
yeah at all so we're gonna do oh so what
you're doing is yeah you're pre-making
these for the space mission and then you
drip water into this yes reconstitute it
yes and then you'll need a grill yes
because you already grilled it Bingo and
it's been done to my specifications you
got a whole Julia Child
look over here look at that we borrowed
a freeze drying machine from our friend
babish thanks Babbage could have done it
without babish
so we're in my basement and I'm showing
everybody my secrets I keep down here
which is uh George Mills I'm in damage
basement and my and the uh this is the
vacuum component of the freeze dryer
that I've used twice and now you guys
are going to help me get some value for
money out of thank God
wow ah okay message for space uh good
good luck be safe and eat well thank you
[Music]
is like
it sounds like it's a truck
drivers to go
yes we did a lot of tests this week look
at that it's perfect
it's perfect
you know what this looks like no no no
that's fine yeah
[Music]
okay yeah so you so you promised me this
will taste good it's not perfect but
it's also not crap either right looks
like crap but it's not crap so come here
it looks like crap another thing I
learned from being obsessed with what
goes on in space food is that you can't
have buns there's no Brattle out right
because of because it's crumbly screw
that up who is it somebody smuggled
something
someone smiled the corned beef sandwich
so it's not it's not that space hates
bread it's that bread has crumbs and
once again the crumbs float so in space
I think a lot of sandwiches are flour
tortillas yeah yes the flour tortillas
yeah these are actually a little bit of
large or friends of mine so here we go
ready okay so one of these was one of
those exactly we rehydrated these for
about 45 minutes long it takes gonna do
that it's a loud noise all right okay
ready for this one it look good look at
that it's even steaming and wonderful
that's for you wow the cheese is in
there more onions are in there the salt
is in there this I think it's fine the
way it is but I what I understand from
the astronauts
so Sean Evans uh sent us uh the classic
the number one this is the first one
it's pretty mild right okay one more
yeah a little more
cheers let's do it
it's all built in what do you think one
stop shopping
I thought it was good wow and you did it
right you freeze-dried it reconstitute
it we're good all good okay
um
and just trust me the Burger that I had
at the laboratory at NASA
no we're doing better bro for sure okay
thank you
[Laughter]
pouch me Neil voucher meal but I like
your mutton chops I used to have those
when they were in style
ready for the next mission
should I decide to accept it
ready for the next missions let's do
this mission number two
tonic ideal the burger I think we should
send to the Future and the other day I
was watching an interview with Steven
Spielberg he said what if there are
aliens out there and what if they're
actually future us they're not really
from another galaxy they're actually
fuss in the future coming back I want to
make the burger
we're coming back what coming back from
the future
made a time machine yeah okay I think
they're going back to just see how we
screwed everything up right but at this
moment we're making great Burgers we
keep them simple we make great Burgers
what if we could make a burger that we
could send to the Future
right the next mission is to make the
platonic ideal okay we're gonna make
this it's your idea of a platonic idea
and it's very similar to be clear right
my idea of a potato I know you're a
burger guy but to say this is the
platonic idea I know it's a scientist
as a scientist Precision right matters
simple again only a few ingredients here
I'm gonna go back to the dawn of the
hamburger when they to make burgers they
actually they smashed balls of beef nice
so photonic idea yeah right as far as
I'm concerned a Toasted Bun a toasted
potato roll it's squishy but the side is
toasted it's not squishy so that there's
a difference in texture between the two
people it creates a prophylactic barrier
yes greases and whatever don't go down
here right I would have just said
barrier would be enough
[Laughter]
so that's this this is known as the heel
this is crown of the bun right technique
for you there okay it's not gonna do
this right
contact Cash there if you know about
some driving contact now what you got
here what is that what is that so this
is my my own design it's a spatula this
is a heavyweight 12 gauge stainless
steel especially yeah okay
and its own momentum yeah we'll do half
the work right but it also gives you
control who's there it's me
you got to be on my utensils no it's
only on mine
come on I love you man but I'm going to
look at you while I'm cooking my food no
I like the high mass then the gravity
and the momentum gets you halfway there
you're gonna I'm gonna do one you're
gonna okay ready watch ready oh
straight down notice how I'm off to the
side like that see that that's stuck
already oh there you go see and then
there's still more to go so I want to go
off the center let it peek out the
bottom there
okay look at that what you you didn't
smash it you mashed it this is very good
it's okay notice the difference you're
actually right the Hulk deal smash it
making all this time of making mash
Burgers okay yeah
he does that yeah so this is smash law
I'm ready to do that but that's not what
you did you lose control touched it and
mashed it so this is a mascula okay
there you go you're gonna yeah
I got you there you go she's gonna come
off how do I make it come off here let's
do this you gotta let's give it a little
bit there we go okay feels gravity right
yeah not too bad I'm gonna give it a
little more so you can get the edges
there I love the edges there you go
there you go nice look at that okay I'm
gonna change the name of the damn thing
now I have to dope the button it's
called bun doping right I've never heard
of this diced onions we're gonna put a
few pickles and then mustard that's on
the hill that's on the hill yeah
good memory there
keeping up I do astrophysics I don't
need a compliment that I remember the
word heal from 90 seconds ago okay so we
did it oh here we go okay good there we
go question yes
this is way smaller than that right this
is a scraper is there a reason for that
there's a reason why because I like to
be able if I have a lot of burgers going
I have to be able to reach over
surgically get in exactly otherwise it's
clumsy in the thinking of maneuver good
troll I need control I need less control
cases what good is power control very
good so slice of American cheese that
lives on here
do this make some room there you go
control
let's eat it then here we go one patty
it's chocolate it's a double
cheeseburger and we're gonna cut it in
half we're gonna share it don't worry oh
we have here at the botanic ideal I
think
look at that it's medium well it's
perfect yeah yeah perfect
[Music]
that's good oh it's juicy juicy yeah
yeah that's the idea
this is the Burger I want to send to the
future you know what's good about this
do onions and pickles as intense as they
are if you eat them straight yeah
are they belong they're tempered
tempered yeah
and you didn't even cook them or
anything you just laid it down huh no
it's
additive rather than sort of
instrumental to what's going on exactly
and again this was proven over 120 years
ago and we got away from this
I mean there's so many absurd burgers
out there that have mac and cheese on it
and as you as you briefly pointed out
too many ingredients so it doesn't work
to me grease is a condiment
so what you would do is you'd send this
into the future because they probably
forgot about it yeah in the same way
somebody should go back and recover the
McDonald's french fries that were made
with lard right that's a girl forgotten
long forgotten unfortunately actually
like in Renaissance Europe they forgot
how to make arches and they forgot stuff
that the Romans had figured out has to
be rediscovered so yeah you see the
value in this done yes I do yeah make a
deal I do we did it
mission complete if I were to do this
myself I would make
two burgers out of this in economics
there's something called a util okay
which is a unit of satisfaction right
that's why when you buy candy bars often
there's two of them yes like what the
hell is the point because you eat one
you have the satisfaction of beginning
and ending one and then you have another
one yeah so you have more utils of
satisfaction eating two
of something even if the weight of those
two equals the weight of one they do
otherwise right so I would order two
separate hamburgers yes and then I'd
have two occasions to smile I'm with you
yes
[Laughter]
um we are Stardust
is the hamburger start us
the cry out that
we are Stardust right we're the origin
of our chemical elements is traceable
crucibles of stars right is it
manufactured elements up the periodic
table
from its base ingredients of hydrogen
and helium
we are Stardust
refers not only to humans right but to
all living things on earth
in fact it includes Earth itself
whoa the burger has its place
thank you Neil within it
thank you
wow thank you we did the right thing we
brought Neil deGrasse Tyson
on the show
wow thank you
okay time for me to Bean back here we go
thanks for coming ready
[Music]
[Laughter]
George modes Burger scholar here please
like And subscribe watch more episodes
hit a button somewhere here hang on I
got a phone call get air
Neil what happened you okay